- Yeah, there we go.
This is perfect.
- Is this squeeze enough for you?
No I mean, maybe a little close.
Have you ever heard of Yahoo Answers.
- Went on there a couple times
for a couple things I'm
not goin' talk about but.
- We're gonna try to solve some
of the most ridiculous ones.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- That could be dangerous.
- I would say go straight
to the emergency room.
- Any advice?
- I know that it's a really
stressful time right now,
and it's going to be a horrible 24 hours
while it makes its way
through your system.
You're gonna feel it
but just wait 24 hours.
Wait it out an you'll poop it out
and I'm excited for you.
- It will poop out.
- Oh yeah.
The whole ice cube absolutely.
- Duh.
- Two.
- Two?
- I think two.
- Why is that? Why two?
- I don't know.
They grow faster than humans.
So it seems like their
brain would be more mature.
- Birth.
- Birth?
- At birth.
- As soon as they start
humping themselves.
- Dogs don't talk.
- They know.
- When are we talking to dogs?
- Of course they can.
Every creature on earth can have fun.
- Obviously yeah.
- What do you think they have fun doing?
- Sewing webs.
- Spider can have.
Spiders turn up all the time.
- They probably have the most fun.
- They can swing.
- They have so much fun.
- They having fun, we just don't know.
- You can eat it.
- I mean, it's still kind of baked
but it's more
- Once you chew it.
- Digested, it's
- It's pretty much the consistency
of once you started stirring it.
- That is not possible.
- How do we do it?
- I don't know.
- Drake needs to know.
This man named Drake needs to know
how to unbake his cake.
- So he overcooked it
- And he thinks it's reversible.
That is.
It's not reversible.
- Did your dog bring like ham in the bed
and it was in your pants sweating?
- If you aren't circumcized,
you get a thing called smegma.
- Okay here's an anatomy lesson coming.
- There's this cheesy like substance
that stinks every now and then
and you gotta wash your
privates really well.
So maybe he's got smegma.
Leaking down to his balls.
- Does he have ugly hands?
He's a plumber.
- He's a plumber.
- Yeah.
- Cause he's a plumber
and he needs to wear.
That's a logical answer.
- The handyman.
He's a handyman.
- A handyman.
- I think that there might
be some way you can find
with the food that he's
eating, who prepared the food.
You know that's a tough one.
- I like that as a parent,
you're thinking about your
child's sexual orientation
and I hope that you're
asking that question
because you wanna be supportive,
if your turtle does turn out to be
part of the LGBTQ community.
- Which could be so grateful
to have your turtle.
- So I would just say raise him or her
in an inclusive environment.
- Probably.
- Do you?
- No, sorry.
- No.
- No?
- You don't find.
What about when he turns into a human?
- When he's a human, he's a gorgeous man.
- Have you ever heard of blubbering?
(laughs)
- No, you wanna tell me what that is?
- You have to ask Yahoo.
- [Host] Oh I see.
I'll figure it out.